well Brian a lot of parents commenting
on social media recently about this
matter
nowhere in this thirty three page
document which we have up on our website
does it say how the district can support
students with special needs a concern as
parents wait and see how trustees decide
to address the issue what are they going
to do because my son
struggles Danielle Pierce worries about
her eldest child Christian arising CCSD
freshman with special needs my oldest
has requiring him to have an
individualized education plan my son
really craves socialization but Pierce
questions his success at school this
year with the current CCSD reopening
proposal my child cannot perform at the
same level of his peers and I will not
have him being graded like that we have
to find ways to support them CCSD
superintendent dr. hey-zeus Jarra says
the district is considering various
options one of the ideas and one of the
things that we have on that Wednesday is
for students to you know provide some
small group instruction being live in
the classroom is the best is the best
option and Harry Quinny teaches special
education at Kitty Ward Elementary
School despite the district not
specifically addressing special
education students she awaits what
decisions CCSD makes I wouldn't want to
throw everybody back in into the
classroom if it wasn't safe alright so
tonight of course CCSD is looking at
that dr. Jarris has into eyes into
education plans is something the
district is quote ironing out he wants
something available for the board about
this issue on July 9th in the newsroom
Kristin Drummond 8 News now